top of the why is it getting cut off
there that doesn't make any sense
I mean hey this is a real background
okay welcome to another live stream it's
gonna be a live play of Episode four of
Walking Dead I thought if you're
watching this offline check out the
number in the description click on that
and that will take you right to the game
I'm just gonna wait a little bit to get
like people in here thank you for the
welcoming back that yes we're waiting a
lot of streaming today it's just really
fun doing outlast this will be probably
a bit more chill I hope because I'm
getting a little tired it takes a lot of
energy to stream prompts the streamers
for [ __ ] doing this everyday jingle
man sup thank you guys for waiting for
me and back says it's two people no two
people watching that's not correct
someone was never like I'll do it I'll
do a quick tweet to make sure people
know I'm live this time I want people
missing it see if I can find the streams
shaming calm he gave me that
youtube.com/ it's so weird to write
notice since I'm playing outlast that's
not it Walking Dead
there we go being saved
so I had to buy the game again because
it didn't unlock episode 4 to me so many
people were like why aren't you playing
it it's not a you [ __ ] [ __ ] but
I'm like dude I can't play it it said I
said it wasn't unlocked so I had to buy
it again super annoying I don't know
what's up with that
Madi Australia is now awake what time is
it in Australia yeah that's such a weird
country I'm gonna save our nightmares
for next time
chubs is in here [ __ ] me you're
streaming in yeah that's right I'm
greedy like that
how long are you gonna be streaming uh
probably an hour and a half I think
can't express how much I love you chubs
even though you're overweight chubs is a
beautiful man all right he's a perfect
body and a perfect soul and every inch
of fat on his body I love I would
personally lick it
join the discord what's the [ __ ]
discord you guys made one I had chubs
his donut at 10 bucks beers on me if we
ever made up dude preciate you promote
Jack to even new rank I think Jack
you're doing a good job I appreciate you
Holly green thank you I am finger the
sound board for me Jesus Christ I need
to update this [ __ ] [ __ ] I really
there's so many games coming out lately
Anna I don't really want to just upload
gameplay so I thought hey why don't want
I just stream it turquoise turtle love
you pissed appreciate yeah okay I got a
girl with me now should be less delaying
my audio is it unless last high were I
mean Australia's - yeah oh it's not that
late I mean 2 a.m. is pretty lame but I
thought it was like 5:00 in the morning
or some [ __ ] can white rub a kid I might
actually sleep now it's getting late
well you can still watch this offline
later Alyssa McCain show us Edgar and
drink a Pepsi
ah you got stuck in my nose the [ __ ]
this this is why you need to drink Pepsi
goddamnit pills make I you laugh you
lose some it no they're a goddamn waste
of time they keep getting claimed by
other people it's not like the D
monetization is bad enough
join the discord what are you what are
you smoking [ __ ] you're talking alright
let's play the [ __ ] game let's play -
[ __ ] game oh I do look so cute
I mean Oregon it's cold
great happy for you alright are you guys
ready are you guys ready should we do
this now Samantha McNew hey poo poo love
you love you right back Samantha
appreciate you okay game capture window
capture give me one second I like set
this [ __ ] up boy
so easy
oops oops
oopsie now let's make me smaller [ __ ]
[ __ ] does this look good does this look
good this is a good spot for walking in
I should put the camera over there
shouldn't I say my name Alex queer love
there you go my name is Geoff
I never yeah Corinne Kay
uh-huh Thank You Josh penis welcome Josh
penis kiss Edgar's butthole there you go
who doesn't love kissing a good old
butthole
sorry Brad I don't have time we're gonna
start playing now Alex :
preciate you welcome everyone welcome
well watch when after study and keep up
the good word love you thank you guys
appreciate you uh do I need anything
it's gonna be an hour and a half I think
usually they are boots overload today
just don't know what to do with myself
yeah it's a lot of streaming I don't
think I ever streamed this much I wanted
to finish outlast and I wanted to finish
the episode walking for I wasn't
actually gonna play this but so many
people wanted me to play it and it seems
fair to finish what we started
sardath when is Episode five out I'm
excited for this one cuz I know a little
spoiler I know we're gonna from a
thumbnail I saw Ken isn't it
so let's go Thank You Coral Roberts on
The Walking Dead
preciate you for having Griffin pet
Edgar's head for me
[Music]
yeah I love that last I thought it was
cool
[ __ ] Garcias you can see their
playthrough persona 5 are you [ __ ]
insane
it's just don't kill me I'm literally
dying game is so [ __ ] long
Joe all this time I
I told you guys to hit the sponsor
button I'm sorry I mean I told you to go
to gaming YouTube [ __ ] calm such
peopie but you can just hit the sponsor
buttons right there we don't need your
help
yeah [ __ ] that guy I hope the feel train
is coming
I don't know explaining yourselves I
asked you to get Kate and Gabe's safe
not talk your tailor pills my brother
huge fans first video I watched how
could you was dong Chungbuk that old Bao
Chun bongos or whatever Thank You Nina
that's awesome I got my church actually
it's really surprised pretty cool thank
you it's a Nina advisees then pramukh -
all right here we go I'm gonna try I'm
gonna try not to get too distracted by
the chat I'll obviously look at it and
talk to you guys I'm in Denmark it's
kind of lame wow this is before yeah
Derek just seemed kinda lame actually
I'm kidding it seems cool I want to
visit again it's been a long time since
I went to Denmark
oh yeah we used to be a baseball player
welcome all the new sponsors Fox and
Jane and appreciate you would be on I'm
out of practice that's all seem here I
haven't held a bath since the league
booted me well boo didn't got all
afternoon to get back in your groove
sorry
oh yeah I'm the friendly chosen holding
this thing makes me feel better that's a
Pinker finger I'm but joke you doing
okay I guess sure I've been wrestling
with something that booty
you're xavier garcia right of the
ballplayer Johnny your autograph hey
we're famous let's find my baseball that
would be so awesome
how can you say no to that oh thank you
this is not how it happens by the way
whenever people greet me they're like
hey are you
PewDiePie I'm like yeah and they're like
are you sure I'm like no and they're
like oh I'm so sorry
personalized crap I'm like I'm kidding
[Music]
why would I make it worthless what an
axle I hope you like it nice cube I
might get ten bucks for this you got to
keep those fans happy big star let's get
back to baseball coral Roberts how do I
sponsor you hit the sponsor button
American random ish there you go
I'm gonna hit it I'm gonna hit it crush
it
why wouldn't I crush it it's out of here
holy cow
you just had to rub it in didn't you
just talking like that make you feel
better
why what's the matter you should try it
ah son of a [ __ ]
strike two then knock that [ __ ] off I'm
serious you just talk talk talk it's
annoying
geez you gotta learn to relax David what
do you suggest put some money on it yes
this is a Sarah deaf playthrough
everyone do that anymore I still can't
believe you actually wanted to come here
if I were in your situation and avoid
batting cages forever well thanks for
bringing me anyway whiskey-dick she'd do
well crush it I'm gonna get some whiskey
for all this Garcia super chat I think
your ego is boosted plenty next time we
go to the shooting range
I don't really shoot I'll get some
whiskey after this dream a good arms
throbbing Garcia takes one for the team
that's gotta hurt god dammit javi I
[ __ ] warned you someone rang my door
I remembering any Shana you how to play
this game that well let this Superstar
return the favor Doris that's weird
that's really weird
no one should be here
crush it help guys I'm scared I got it
you don't have to rub away my face I'm
done no gasps damn it take me knock off
the tantrum grow up you just can't
resist making your little dinner Canyon
once again it's hot in a star thinking
he's better than me it's too close
that's gonna change what's going on
David I don't understand you don't
understand because you only think about
yourself and I'm sick of it it's been
that way for years I've been looking out
for yourself I'm just sick of your
attitude David you love to mock me but
you have no idea what I deal with my job
sucks okay and I fight like cats and
dogs I belong back in the army I had a
purpose there well you sell a [ __ ] I
respect last time you deployed you
didn't have kids so whatever you do now
you gotta put them for us a little bit
then I am putting them first that's why
I have to leave things between me and
Kate have been going downhill for a
while
but if I left it seemed like that would
be best for everyone he really liked
he's pretending this is the life I want
my kids are too young not anymore
I once I'm not gonna stand in your way
that's right well alright then
I'm not gonna lie if I go it's gonna be
hard on everyone just go Kate may need
help from time to time then maybe you
should have been living there you won't
leave her hanging
I need to know that I'll be there for
them that's right you won't I'll be
there for them [ __ ] here why you
should go about time you grew up come on
I want to get out of here now
the brothers gonna die the brothers
definitely gonna die
shout out to diet coke kitty what a
great name well I'm more of a Pepsi guy
are you - Jon's gonna figure out what to
do with you she's making no [ __ ] is
wrong with that guy's face hey everybody
just take a breath all right I was just
trying to tell them that's your mistake
right there you can't fight everybody
understand that Joan's not looking for
revenge she just wants to order
cooperation is the name of the game
there's still a way through this but
you've got to let Joan enforce the laws
I'll ill I'll see what I can do what
you're gonna choose that winch over
beam-out he said others leading here
what brother javi he needs to get with
the program
you boys want to make it out of here
just relax and trust in the process
trust in the process can I see that guy
again that looks like a [ __ ] potato
he was amazing he's my hero after I
brought you in after I saved your asses
this is how you treat me
betrayal lies I wanted to follow your
plan David Kate wanted to escape she's
scared you're telling me my own wife
tried to [ __ ] me over now she's trying
to [ __ ] that for me you have any
understanding of lying to me I'm being
set up and I don't even want to think
about what they'll do when they find
Kate I could have found a way to protect
all of you but now now you're all on
your own
you gotta still have some friends here
right I thought Lonnie was a friend he
turned on me and you shot him any
friends you haven't killed haven't
killed you yet it's everyone out for
themselves these days we can beat him
come on
we keep still win this heat keep your
head about able to take down some
punk-ass soldiers you were so goddamn
naive javi we were outnumbered here I
could be far away from here
there are other communities out there
I'm right here with you man we don't
have to run we can handle it
whoa war never changes sorry I'm just
adjusting my problem is I don't know
what to do now there's no way out of
this
they got us boxed in here literally be
ready for anything so we just have to
get ready take the opportunities as they
come
just like pitches right ha be exactly
like pitches uh he smiled
that's so cute you two seem ready for
anything
armed escort you're that scared to face
me Oh David I'm not scared of you
he came here to talk tonight Alex you're
not gonna be a problem
are you I just want a calm discussion
between us I won't be a problem if you
let us go in fact I may even be friendly
I'm Peter Flores I can't do that but I
like what you're trying to do people had
concerns about me coming here after the
way you murdered Lonnie David the guy
with the glasses and you need to hear
about it it's get to viewing there's
trouble oh come on
just tell us I'm getting to it those
raids were unfortunate but necessary oh
[ __ ] she knew about him danger was
another long winter I should have been
told about this David you remember how
many friends we lost last year I
couldn't bear to see it happen again
tomorrow morning I'm gonna call for a
gathering in the square the people
deserve to hear a full explanation of
your arrest and then then you'll be
replaced as head of security oh no one's
above the law David not even you well if
he's head of I know the laws Joan you're
the one breaking them your scheme is
gonna blow up in your face
just wait I really hope not I'm
responsible for the lives of everyone in
this community
you set me up everyone's gonna see
through your lies I did what I had to do
to keep the people of Richmond safe
they're going to see that and they'll
also see that the biggest threat to them
right now is you will debate all of this
in the morning right now David I need to
ask you some questions
in private does anyone know if this
episode is good or not I really hope
it's like Walking Dead Season one wasn't
that great until like the last four or
five episodes it's been kind of slow
before I don't know hey it's me everyone
top of the morning this is episode four
someone just asked there's a plant down
here that's nice how the [ __ ] does this
plant live down here on the ground hey
we have a plant let's let's stand on
this bench I'm not gonna get up there
from this bench hmm hmm let's look in
the lockers nothing useful here well
well well well
well top of the mornin what are we a
it's a palace we call that in Sweden
what do you call it in your language wow
that's really interesting Oh Edgar
farted for [ __ ] sake why do you do
this to me
take it take the pot you're banned
get out
why did why does dogs fart smell so bad
I'm jealous
I'm saying it because I'm Joe no time to
rest listen I want you to get the things
you can get up there
what do we got oh [ __ ]
chicky chicky okay now we have that and
doesn't look very sturdy what's up
Rommel major shout out to remain remain
chat okay
those boards come loose what are you
some kick it nope
okay so use the pipe
I run Sheldon please respond
I love you as family thank you
appreciate you keep up the good work man
people usually ask for shout out no need
for that just one wish you can say hi on
my radio what we're going sane okay hi
to nourish hi-yah [ __ ] sake yeah DL
press I had to self-promote follow me on
instagram yeah D the torus ja d the
terrorists uploads pictures of his
butthole on Instagram it's not something
that you were interested in why am I
stuck in the sea it's [ __ ] harder to
there we gonna hear something in a long
time since I hit the showers
well and I could use one too bad there's
no running water in here okay
excuse it anyway
well that's about the kind of day I'm
having
nice help
help guys I'm stuck [ __ ]
what happens when all the head said it's
his upstairs I wanted to try this one
out supporting the channel that's all
carry on thank you for your call I
appreciate you that's a kiss for you
it's supposed to be good this episode
now through here how do you know
we've looked at that stool like a
million times look at the window we did
could squeeze through there so he's
saying we can squeeze through there just
need to find a way to get there
[Music]
behind the giant that's an old stream
reference now I can grab this that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] seriously oh my god are
you kidding me
Wow Wow and no one and no one else that
was locked down here thought about you
doing that are you kidding me
yeah this episode is good and what the
[ __ ] you're talking about behind the
[ __ ] giant listen to me son Kate I
wasn't sure how I was going to find you
then I heard the glass breaking thanks
baby you're alive
let's go make some zombie baby you
escaped the guards barely we got to get
you out of here take this help me pry
these bars off give it a push from your
side push it to the limit it just shakes
off of course that's how metal works
right now just shake it up if you have a
stuck in prison just shake those bars
off that works ten out of ten ten yes
check the bad dog as well in fact is
sexy now yeah hell yeah
finest all that noise grab her by the
what it's
you've got this place surrounded come on
see what I don't understand is why
doesn't the zombies just fight why don't
they just fight them we kung fu you know
has anyone thought about that think
about taking me Eleanor found a place
Gabe there with the others we've been
hiding out there he's Gabe all right
he'd rather be charging in to see if
David right now ah [ __ ] him
I convinced him to be cautious Gabe is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] we should probably keep
moving
where are the patrols oh they're around
I had some close calls on my way to find
you almost got caught
but thanks for risking it baby thanks
for risking it now let's go guts make
some I owe you my life it's only fair
don't worry I think we're even
all clear come on yeah boy why are you
doing streams instead of uploading
videos because my videos get demonetized
if I stream at least I get some the
quarantine building what there's no
editing required for these type of
videos anyways they make sense is my
life anymore but he doesn't deserve to
be locked away he knows it was your idea
to leave him behind
Oh God apes but he's got bigger things
to worry about right now oh hi hold up
yeah where's Clementine that's a good
pressing ok lead the way
well there's a nice shoes why you look
so angry and I think I'm just tired I'm
really not angry before they find the
room empty I noticed it too I knew like
okay we're gonna make them keep looking
because we're about it how to Richmond
soon not soon enough
that's on the Norse place yeah minute
action for fun yet not much happens in
these there's a lot of activity all of a
sudden I don't like this
dreams are also accepted lose sleep
thank you come on let's get inside
brand new Nikes yes I'll have a rest
after this I think when I squint with my
eyes you know cuz I I don't really have
that good vision I'm wearing contacts
but I think I need to get new ones
so I squint and then I look really angry
I'm really happy guys
promise
[Music]
if if Clementine dies in this one I'm
going to
eat anchor Holly each type care if
Clementine dissector dice that I are
dead here issue debt right
[Music]
without tire it is
which what are you doing
[Music]
why not just wear your glasses I hate
wearing glasses
I don't like myself in glasses never
never had it just doesn't fit me I feel
like when you wear glasses is sort of
like part of your identity
it's just
it's just like I don't want that it
might be it's nice sometimes
[Music]
I feel like a lot of people are gonna
die in this one yeah I agree with you
Sean I hope so oh and some people dying
man I want people to die
thicker than water he's talking about
[ __ ] he just farted because I squeezed
him why thank you
[Music]
hey buddy hey buddy how you doing to see
you ah be really your goofy face and
everything I thought you left that he's
expect to find you here I mean Kate said
you were here but I thought I went
looking for my dad but couldn't find him
thanks Alex
I just can't do this now oh hey
Abhishek Judy well Jack's septic I sucks
now jacksepticeye is one of my favorite
youtubers he's at an actually absolutely
outstanding person I would do a lot of
sexual things with that man but our
contract forbids it that's all I can say
hey trip look who's here hey guys hey
where have you been
that guy's [ __ ] hipster Viking then
we got luck going through me and David
in jail right so you gave these people
more reason to hate us what is going on
here enrichment thanks Chuck Bass
thank knees clear from the rest of us
what do we do
shine is like don't mind I mean join
she's trying to JoVE David from power
told you we couldn't trust him
I want to go save my dad right now oh my
god you're so annoying
no no way it's just too dangerous what
do you guys think she'll be say before
her family is to get out of here of
course you would say that you already
tried running away once thank you so
much guys blows out the window go look
for yourself
all right what do we got what do we got
yeah Moyes mine crash that's a lot of
zombies javi yeah even if you did get
your brother free you're not gonna be
able to go anywhere
that's right hobby Wow as much as I
don't want to be here
you sure are glad we didn't stumble into
that on our own [ __ ] yeah can you
imagine
we dodged a bullet didn't why is the
chat talking about jacksepticeye's me I
think we got luckier than I even want to
think about right now cuz I have a lot
of intestine it's like we're in danger
with in this place and without I for one
would feel a whole lot safer with a few
more guns to protect ourselves that the
smartest move to make right now that's
crazy
he's my brother Kate I have to thank you
Jenny and Adams okay we have to rescue
David I know where those guns my dad
showed me there are lots I can take us
okay sounds like a plan
we'll get back here as soon as we can
good luck come here Kate I just be
careful
can we just [ __ ] her already
sorry family-friendly feelings
look javi I don't know if you've heard
us but I think I [ __ ] it up with
Eleanor we can talk on the way about
that I don't think I can leave this
apartment with things like this between
me and her Oh what the [ __ ] did you do
did you fire in their face I know you
must have at least heard something it
happens especially these days don't
worry about it
Thanks just shouldn't have pushed it
with her like I did was it fair too much
going on already right javi come on just
give us a minute pal do I ever watch
other people play the same game I play
uh no sometimes I do watch you trip get
over it damnit it's fun to watch you
were my friend
how other people are reacting the same
things that you're like holy [ __ ] that
was awesome I want to see how that
person reacted I'll talk it over with
Eleanor and watch over things here
you've got my word I won't let anything
happen to anyone
Thank You javi come on good luck
his name should really just be hipster
Viking honestly that's what he is
hey and we're on part 2 part 3 be
careful
place fancy wine okay this will be green
back here that's a terrible attitude
that be shame for his mother it is so
annoying I agree no you haven't keep not
really some decisions you make them in a
split second and then have to carry them
the rest of it yeah dl i Quevedo pills
that shot I got so many comments over my
pothole I appreciate all I'm answering
and for real yadi yadi life hours I want
to ask you if you don't that's all I can
say what do you mean avi if you get mad
and you feel your life is in danger
it's show no mercy man you are more
important to me than any of these other
people I not the girl that I disagree
where's Clementine where's [ __ ]
Clementine it's that guy doesn't he look
weird time to backhand game I feel like
yeah he needs anything if it comes to
that game it's like the new dot takeaway
from that was supposed to be to protect
yourself first and last okay don't hurt
anybody unless you have to okay we don't
want to make any noise and attract any
attention hey I can go talk to him
well you sneak inside I'll distract him
you won't do anything to me it's a good
idea Gabe I can do this
come on Gabe hey come on Gabe well hey I
saw something my butthole surely Oh
he's gonna show him his butt Oh what
yeah man hey I saw something
show me yeah that's how people talk not
like what was it where what happened
tell me notices like okay let's go over
here now uh need more Rick and Morty
games yeah I want to play more of that
that was really fun before the first I
did I just I'll do it I promise that
Rick and Morty episode didn't get Dee
monetize as well it's [ __ ] amazing I
don't know how it made it through that
thumbnail man a [ __ ] thumbnail of the
plumpest
why hasn't he died yet this is a Sarah
deaf playthrough oh you meant game told
you it would work
good work buddy yeah mediocre work I
don't know what else to say really like
it was okay work maybe Clem is finding a
je that makes sense that's a good point
it's down here
the guns are through that door I would
love to play more paradigm as well
locked this is too many games can I vote
for key either pinstripe and all these
games man I have to do this the hard way
okay okay that was loud okay that's
extremely loud
[Laughter]
oh my god no spoilers in the chat guys
come on they like to show shoots in this
game hell yeah what's your go-to
apocalypse gun
I don't know
I never really shot a rifle as I
honestly I don't know I guess a ak-47 I
know it's sad I don't live in America
sad times put these in your back
we never done this before you and me we
make a pretty good team right
the uncle-nephew one-two punch no I get
fine yeah we do look at it less [ __ ] no
one heard him come in are you serious
what the hell are you doing here not
loading up all that we're trapped here
in town there's a herd at the gates no
matter what's going on out there I need
to be able to protect my family
Javier that herd is the least of your
[ __ ] problems right now was a [ __ ]
thing to do [ __ ] off on me like that
I know why didn't you meet me at the
stronghold we had a plan
I just can't be a part of what's going
on in New Richmond yeah [ __ ] lying even
in the stealing what are you doing then
I know he'd want me to help you no
matter what
but why should I trust you now oh my god
just tell you're nothing but trouble
we're desperate
yeah we need you a lot more than you
need us I know but we need you that's
about the most pathetic plea I've ever
heard come on babe you're lucky I've got
a thing for underdogs okay you know I'm
in and it looks like you could use all
the help you can get awesome I gotta
grab something else god I need by the
front at 5:00 [ __ ] okay please please
can Gabe die in this episode please
that's all I want for Gabe to die please
please Gabe
please just die please oh man look at
that I pressed all right pretty good
there no pretty proud of myself there
for that one
did Jesus die where do these ago whoa
another hipster uh he can't he can't
shoot me is the [ __ ] hipster get away
oh [ __ ]
hipster means business what the [ __ ]
Jesus left he was like I'm done with you
guys oh [ __ ] we got [ __ ] stabbed in
the shuffle Vegas glasses you're
bleeding
Simon okay that's a bit mean oh my god
the [ __ ] game I'll be fine
are you sure I'm so sorry yes I'll be
fine
don't worry about it you have to get
back to the others gage has definitely
been two minutes can i he's still alive
yeah I like been just passed though
starting to think siding with you might
have not been the best idea I was so sad
when I season it looks like Jen Hey look
I get to drag him
that's a really fun it's really bleeding
oh really that taken care of [ __ ] no
it's okay lingard and David are close
friends we can count on him to help you
medical facilities right nearby it'll be
quiet this time and I - yeah okay but
let's be quick
that guy just popped out a [ __ ] knife
out of nowhere it's like dude chill I
will get that knife that looks like a
good night [ __ ] hipster Kent stabbing
me what ask me really it targets over a
mile away not these but some models javi
it's probably best if lingard doesn't
see these guns he and David might be
tight but he's still part of Richmond's
Leadership Council
I'll keep watch with Eva okay do any of
them have laser sights god damn it Gabe
don't make me laugh don't make me like
you [ __ ] you well what is he doing
transplanting blood ran into a little
trouble wow that looks like it must have
hurt I just need to get it cleaned up
yes he surprised me climb it cool
thought you were someone else
that you left clamp thought you'd be
long gone by now so did I but I still
need to talk about AJ with leaned guard
look at him
is this celli way I can't leave Richmond
would that hurt out there
something tells me lingard doesn't care
what you're doing he's been out of it
since I got here he's alive poor dumb
bastard that's gonna need more than just
cleaning javi I can stitch that for you
I can't promise it'll look great once it
heals time for what does that mean all
right go for it all right go for it but
if I lose my arm is gonna be awkward ha
ha you'll be fine I've dealt with worse
huh let me see if I can find a needle
and thread for that Clark are you ok I'm
fine
I started bleeding it's a thing traveled
with women before and they all had it it
means you're growing up why am I having
this conversation Jordan you know like
womanhood okay you take over your bodies
is developing and then things changed
but it'll be okay
okay I can take your taki she can help
you with uh javi worry about yourself
right now we need to find a needle and
thread to stitch you up first right well
you were right that was awkward
hey minx is playing outlast [ __ ] I'm on
my other account because they didn't
work on the other I forgot I'm proud I'm
not offline let me just go offline in
case something right talk to me
lingard it's not like German or wow that
guy is really out of it
third soms there's some water Adam no
okay well then I don't [ __ ] know man
see if we can find some tampons here for
you Clemmy play Hillary Clinton in the
background know what I'm looking for
Clinton confirmed jackpot needle and
thread all right we got what we wanted I
realized and ready to go okay
hey let's go in the interwebs and look
up some with the internet still work if
there's the apocalypse do you think like
that [ __ ] would still be run running
what were they everything unlike that
communication go down it's like if
internet goes down and there's zombies I
just seems like way too much effort Wow
God Edgar's losing so much [ __ ] Harry
we go Harry and you probably can't see
but my sweaters like ruin dog problems
here you go climate do you do you wanna
do you wanna at Joanna hello this is
just what you're looking for
they help you handle it Kate will take
care of you you want to eat them as fast
as you can and that way it works
it works on your body better think I
remember how to do this
okay hold still
try not to breathe damn that six-pack
though what the but look I know I'm
probably not the best person to talk to
about that stuff before you weren't that
bad thanks for you know being here yeah
thanks for saying like it yeah basically
all this means is you could become a mom
if you want it funny I already felt like
a mom can he used to say I was the
natural-born mother
what what just happened what just
happened what what are we going we come
back in ten baby we going back [ __ ]
dumb that's a bird you did it one
another
sorry what you wanted to do next can i
what do you guys think how about a
rabbit dude how'd she do that that's
pretty good rabbit he'd laugh his ass
off Oh candy bar oh [ __ ] hey grab the
lighter out the duffle will you why I uh
wish sigh doesn't matter
what she coyly didn't even push it there
I really hope Clementine doesn't get
pregnant that we will you'd just a
second goofball voila
what the [ __ ] where do you come from
well you don't have a weapon ready smack
smack heli damn climb it a clue knows
what to do is he okay not bitten okay
unfortunately you know the chatters the
time I saw you holding AJ it just looked
so natural somewhere up there his mama
is looking down on you grateful for what
you're doing always putting him first
you've done as much for AJ as I have
yeah Kenny don't Becca would be grateful
for you - yeah but you're the only mama
he's gone oh yeah it was Rebecca's mom I
forgot about that protective so long ago
Karen all the things a good parent needs
to be and all at your age but Parenthood
is a hell of a motivator though that's
for sure that kind of love I would get
but it's worth dying for
I guess that's what caught you felt when
duck yep oh that was a long time ago
Kenny's beard it's better than yours
never will be thank you I was literally
thinking that as well I'm sick of the
cold as I am it's not even that great
sorry
snow you surviving out here hoping that
Wellington will take us in someday I bet
we find some good people down in Florida
maybe even a little friend for this
goofball wouldn't that be nice we could
use the company
there aren't any good people anymore
if there aren't it's because we keep
loosing them like Sarita
that day outside house you were just
trying to save her life I never thanked
you for that you're welcome
yeah you you're welcome life doesn't
mean much without people you can relate
to
Sarita always said family is what you
make it
she was right that's sweet
I'm sorry for all this sappy [ __ ] no
Kane no I guess I'm just happy talking
give him a hug come on bring it air
Kenny boy bring any all right all right
all right enough SAP Kenny how about
this one little man whoa that's a
[ __ ] deer [ __ ] how do you do that
that's [ __ ] dope man you got each
other Danis we have that we'll be okay
well we know what's gonna happen it's
not gonna be okay everyone's gonna die
horrible death
welcome to Walking Dead one month later
thank you jebin it's nice you are nice
indeed
the baby's uglier than my baked more
sucker baby noise shut up again no one
likes you baby I didn't realize thank
you kind of crappy that's a guy there
come out come out of there now
alright alright oh yeah that's how they
met just me I forgot how that's how they
met
what the hell do you want I'm really
glad I found you
Clementine I know this is hard I'm so
sorry about what happened with AJ really
I am
you have to give AJ back please he needs
me I need him that's just not gonna
happen
Clem great thank you it's not much but
here is a Jain there
hey we got oh it's a picture that AJ
wrote
they're going to kill call em up I'm
sure no they're never gonna kill a
client is the only character left from
season one I swear to God
got old Chilean beans
nothing that good out chili and beans
can never saw thank you they'd wanted
you to have that that's thank you you're
welcome
consider it a peace offering we care
about you are almighty there's gonna be
live no one even if it feels wrong
people can still be trying to do the
right thing by you but I'm enjoying
having you brother right now
you're hurting whatever you do you can't
let what happened to get to you you need
to keep a level head plan for after that
you're strong but that won't get you far
if you don't know what you're doing oh
I'll keep fighting you guys gave me no
other choice not time for that anymore
Clem your focus has to be on you now
that's all you can do for me staying
alive has always been about finding
people I could trust as much as they
trusted me that's what the new frontier
has been a silver lining
made me feel worth a damn kept me going
in the worst of times you're slow I know
you will know someone or something yeah
you guys too heavily you never mentioned
him
he took care of me for a while late
every time I would look Jay I could hear
him in my head
helping me guiding me he's still with
you you know here that's amazing
AJ from the first time we met right here
surrounded by absolute hell you and AJ
were a light in the darkness hope for a
better world that's who you are
promise me you'll never lose that light
please
it's what makes you special Clem it's
what keeps the rest of us going I just
AM promised that she would stop talking
you're a tough kid don't change I should
get back before anyone notices I'm gone
remember to keep the focus on you now
Clem and when you need a little extra
support
there's an old airfield about 10 or so
miles south of here
Prescott there are good people there
I'm sure they'll help you out I'll miss
having you around Clem okay let's just
keep it friendly you're going to be okay
thanks Ava good luck out there plum can
something meaningful happen pileus
completely pointless that scene that's
what keeps me going
there's things I have to stay alive to
do okay great thanks for that so what do
you think I think I'm getting better
nice work nice work I wish we could do
it that would be my help
like in season two you got to show
yourself up when as Clementine I was
really coming I still have to ask
lingard about AJ
Hey look I finally wake up
have you thought you were running a cell
with David there any chance he got out
too I hate to think about what Joan
might do to him none of your business
there's a [ __ ] egg shooting okay well
now I have to follow you on Instagram
Jesus Christ like time you there's no
need
tone I look like someone who gives a
[ __ ] what you're up to
frankly I've had enough backstabbing to
last me a lifetime
why do you care if David got out he
deserves what's coming to him if you
think that you don't know David I know
he's the reason I lost AJ when AJ
recovered David was the one who stepped
up took personal responsibility for that
kid you say that like it's a good thing
[ __ ] you this guy's really doubt he was
a positive influence David's the reason
the kids bed off thanks fun parents
don't repair he's ever been you can be
as mad as you want
and how things pan out Clem is AJ's
family no kid is better off when you
break their family apart can we kill
Samus now maybe maybe AJ should be with
Clem all I know is that he's better than
he was when he got here no thanks to you
or David I stand by what I said if
David's taken such good care of him
why did he tell me to ask you where AJ
is that's what this is about then you
you want to know where the boy is
yeah what do you think goddamn what do
you want uh I just wanted to uh I want
you to inject this into me why don't you
do it yourself why don't you do it
yourself
kans I'm [ __ ] cow when your brother
found me
he got me to care about everything I'd
given up on my life other people even
this goddamn place without him around
I don't want to care anymore that's okay
just tell me where he is
then you won't have any reason to do it
okay so
we're gonna have to kill him [ __ ] yet
that's easy I have to know I've been
looking for too long why would we not
kill it I can't lose him now kill him
alright kill that [ __ ] well where is he
what I mean don't do it why not don't do
it he's is that the McCarran ranch few
miles west of here he's really alive
okay we're getting find him now don't
forget to stick around handle the after
pot I don't want to become one of those
monsters don't forget Jones looking for
you and your eyes this guy so [ __ ]
weird better hope she doesn't very mixed
comments so many people saying do it
other people are saying don't do it I've
got it
[Music]
stabbed it is that bad but at that
better oh don't it is [ __ ] Hey Oh
she'll anyway
oh damn say hi common time don't go in
there surprised to see you here
don't flirt with Clementine don't say hi
to Clementine don't look at Clementine
Gabe if you douche if you so much as
even one bit of hair is on Clementine I
will shave your entire body and dip it
in olive oil and I'll let you on fire
that doesn't make any elf ryu like a
chicken how about that yeah yeah no
[ __ ] talk boy you all good yeah we're
all set let's roll
mmm good to see you
that's goddamn right chapter four blood
for blood will anything happen this
episode who knows
lets us wait and see Harvey you're back
hey it's Viking Jesus Clementine
thanks for the warm welcome just
surprised to see you is all guys this is
Eva oh yeah I know she is she's got a
hell of a punch nice to meet you
good to see you Ava
oh hell I see soju okay yeah looks worse
than it is
don't worry about it oh my god I'm down
in the other room for a bit yeah they
were flooding for a while too so you got
the guns huh we got them all right
one for you and one for you you saved
this one for you you get a gun you get a
gun you got one oh that's right Gabe she
already hashed one get the [ __ ] out Gabe
showing it it wouldn't hurt no no of
another what took you so long
we went to see dr. winGuard did Clem
just accept a gun from him just to make
him happy
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] at night ain't good
enough Clem
I'm kind of surprised he was sober it's
gotta be a stressful job looking after
an entire community he was definitely
not a hundred percent there that's for
sure sounds about right
[Music]
why don't you talk to Gabe okay piss me
off game okay
now I want Gabe to die IVA sunrising
whew I think that was bombs people know
we're holed up here and they're gonna
come looking for us
all of us [ __ ] sake maybe it's not as
bad as we think
[ __ ] figures and there's no going
anywhere with those things blocking our
exit they like me that has to help
somehow
just cuz they like you doesn't mean
they're gonna like the rest of us we're
sitting ducks up here we can't just wait
around here to get shot that's for damn
sure
thanks for all their new sponsors by the
way we're [ __ ] [ __ ] oh thanks for that
hobby like we don't know that already we
can't just cut and run not with the hurt
out there like it or not we're [ __ ]
stuck in Richmond how the [ __ ] are we
gonna put the brakes on this thing Jonah
and her people are going to be at the
square right we need to bring the fight
to them Jonah
our problems are soft great okay so how
do we do that
Magnus John will probably have a full
security detail with her we move in fast
guns blazing and we take her out that's
right opal of bullets problem solved yes
after we take Joan out we're gonna need
some way out of this mess
oh yeah Michael I know you can vote or
whatever buddy didn't works well I tried
it before we've got a truck a big one
that we used to use for Walker defense
it's a little busted up but it's way
better than nothing
people are gonna be patrolling these
streets looking for us how far away is
this truck
I'll show you we've been expanding
pushing out further making the safe zone
even bigger can't promise you there's
cool core set a picture that's where the
trucks parked I could spit and hit it we
steal that thing nothing will be able to
stop us steal what hey Jesus
javi is that plus on your shirt you said
it wasn't that bad it isn't
how the hell did this happen oh you're
bleeding right through that bandage you
should have told me as soon as you got
in things went a little sideways at the
end Gabe got in the way a guard came
after me and he stabbed me in the
shoulder I thought you guys were gonna
be careful out there hey don't worry
about it it is what it is thought you
knew what you were doing you're still
alive aren't you Eleanor
can you take a look at this as long as
he keeps it clean it should be okay
would you guys stop making such a big
deal about it
it happened it's over gone already
I'm just trying to make sure he's okay
Gabe what we need to be talking about is
the plan oh I have a bunch of ideas I
want to be the one to go after dad just
give me a gun and I'll do whatever I
know oh the town I know what dad's gonna
be saying shut the [ __ ] up Gabe shut the
[ __ ] up Gabe [ __ ] gay mine
whatever who's to say you're even coming
along kid are you [ __ ] kidding me
so this is [ __ ] Gabe go go I'm not
staying my [ __ ] hold take a breath he's
my dad I'm going out there and I don't
want anyone else getting hurt [ __ ] up
the game hurt is worth it it's worth
dying for this is more important to me
than anyone else I've got a gun and I
know how to use it cut that [ __ ] Gabe
and stop showing off for everybody
you're tough okay you can handle a lot
of [ __ ] you don't have to prove it all
the goddamn time nobody here is gonna
let you be a martyr Gabe
your life is precious okay so you want
to dive-bomb Joan and save the day yes
we have to leave this place is
comfortable is there any option to get a
gate to die handful of people against
everyone out there everything out there
we can do this I know we can let's just
use gaybies shield got a plan and soon
we're gonna have that truck so let's get
started should do the trail I'm still in
I promised David I'd always have us back
let's do it without Conrad you guys need
me and you know it sure as hell seems
that way me Clem Kate and Gabe will go
after the car me and Elinor we'll get
some supplies together here
take a walkie I'll let everyone know
what things kick off the girl is low-key
hot take the other one that keeps
winning no matter what but I'll get my
stuff and meet you at the square okay
let's move out
press beat kill James [ __ ] press alt for
the late system early belief system 32
to kill game got it thank you
initiate Plan gave the human shield
clem you come with me to get the truck
even Kate you guys hang back here be
ready for anything
let's go I think I should go with you
actually
the plant sorry
50 from Beadie rock gaming where it is
flip appeared check out my channel bTW
rocking flick me you means sleepy sleepy
is upstairs I'm gonna get him downstairs
while I'm out there
thank you then appreciate you okay I
guess somebody needs to be a lookout
what nothing
Gabe and I will be fine back here
welcome limits welcome all new sponsors
thank you for everyone that signed
something as a sponsor really appreciate
you appreciate you
welcome to the family welcome as an
airlocks captain if you guys want to
comment just sponsor it up oh look who
just woke up huh what are you doing what
do you do
[Music]
get the [ __ ] out thank you tranquil and
be careful anyone where it was pushing
and those boards on hold up anymore
pushing an egg Gary will fart again and
that way I will dad I will die on this
live stream are you doing what are you
doing again wait Edgar's [ __ ] look
how [ __ ] hairy I am from Edgar by the
way look at this [ __ ] you see this you
don't see it - done
you ruined my [ __ ] life I care
goddammit I'm gonna put him in the cage
because he's pissing me off too much I
don't like you I don't like your farts
you're coming with me boy say bye
everyone say bye to Edgar sorry guys I
didn't really thought I would bad I
guess they should [ __ ]
my headphones fell out does that do
anything can you still hear me
what can ruin all my clothes can't wear
black with a guy she I can't hear
anything
okay still watch this is your working
for you guys and you just got banned
this will happen to you too don't you
worry okay let's keep playing
Beedrill gaming damn typo I meant sleepy
thank you for doing that for us typo
guess they'll be using that for
construction once they've cleared this
area
thank you Mike hatred preciate you my my
hangs out with my video let's go
Vignesh braveness y'all
what are the chances I'd say about 50/50
hey let's run this truck ride over
against balls at least that way he can
get to live that's the deal with game
bob erickson how do I come to sponsor
hit the sponsor button guys hit the
spaceship and risers come on we gotta
hurry and finish before more people come
in early - I can't start the engine not
without attracting a lot of attention
thanks you Alex that one's for you or
should I say Sasuke rest of us are gonna
get behind the truck and push see if we
can't get some distance between us and
them go to gaming youtube.com slash
PewDiePie become a sponsor [ __ ] ads ok
[ __ ] funny we showed you guys ready
welcome Authority is raiding new sponsor
Wow with a lot of pushing here a lot of
pushing going on here holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] ass Demon Souls
x11 seven hello pits 200
elekid's why does claim sound like she's
20 now yeah it's a bit weird she's
supposed to be like 13 right it's a bit
weird at the sexualizing heard a little
too early from my taste
okay I mean a lot to early I heard that
sounded wrong okay okay moving on a bit
shaky do it dude what do you think about
case I live in YouTube is he leaving
YouTube I don't think so dude I searched
you on Instagram you don't you don't I
can't find you I don't like legit can't
find you I feel bad how much you've
donated by legit oh there you are okay
fine I'll finally you please please stop
I'm just kidding appreciate you that
one's for you
should be dibadeaux should be whack I
like check out like I what
appreciate it
appreciate y'all what climate sically a
man wait time is 18 you don't get your
period when you're 8 did you sing you
get it early oh you didn't want me to
come along
trust me I'm a woman I know there's a
fight stay behind just push the truck
Gabe push the truck Gabe you shut the
[ __ ] goddamn trunk alright what do you
think I'm doing I'm doing all the work
you're the one trying to have a
conversation here that's more like it
McNeese don't think those guys will be
able to hear the engine all the way over
here I put it in neutral couldn't find
an ignition key in there guess you'll
have to Hotwire it
try not to shop yourself [ __ ] I'll need
something to strip the wires they left
all their supplies lying around bet
there'll be some tools out there
somewhere just try to hurry okay good
lord this episode is boring well I'm
enjoying [ __ ] over Gabe I'm just
literally just playing this hoping Gabe
will die and making sure Clementine is
safe she's probably between 12 and 14
yeah that's the 13 that's 13 that's what
I said for [ __ ] sake hey hey oh [ __ ] I
didn't know it was your hammer dude
hammer time
ya betch appreciate your tiny pirate
turtle there keep an eye out while I get
it started okay I'll check on the guys
in the office Clem and I will look out
for walkers okay here goes okay which
wire tell me which wire right now Cody
should help with this okay I know the
order whoa Jesus dis dis sick dude just
finishing my shift cheers for getting me
through a dull nine hours here's some of
the cash on cuz I watched you for a half
of my shift off is still not in bed
what are you you've watched all of it
Jesus Christ watch the rest this dream
before I go to bed have a good sunday
mate oh that's so sweet thanks man I
appreciate ya limit mmm
if you follow me on instagram you make
my life complete for [ __ ] sake guys
all right no more [ __ ] what is it
called shoutouts or whatever I don't
want to interrupt the stream with it if
you guys want to comment that's cool but
other people watching guys
come on I don't know why I'm doing this
okay what's all the [ __ ] wires God
connect the battery to the ignition
wait something's wrong with the
lifestream okay they marketing might
there be light is it working now
I hope H 3:8 she doesn't let you take
meaning
to make my favorite videos
it'd really suck if certain type of
conduct can't make it on YouTube like it
said that's just sad to me I think
everyone loves YouTube because it's so
free and you can do whatever you want
but I think things will get better at
good time I'm contributed but right now
if everyone is kind of panicking then
they make sense but I I feel a lot
better when single it's important I'm
getting for you bro so I gets honestly
more than I ever expect
it's very humbling let's go now and
reassuring appreciate
let's fight
that's a temp common all right one more
chapter guys holy [ __ ] demon souls 1 X 1
1 7 yeah no more showers in for this
pizza
with a sound right and just accept my
money don't cut the wrong wire just one
just one for a square is a couple of
just one for you this is a good place to
wait hey Felix it's a good work for me
engine off again
what now I'll check it later we wait for
Ava to call us on the walkie so nothing
for us to do sit and watch the Sun come
up yes [ __ ] time I know we've got
something important to do oh [ __ ] I
forgot Gabe the [ __ ] blockers in the car
god damn teaching you to play euchre
don't that's not a real thing no it's a
card game no honey it's fun no it's nice
to be driving around with a couple kids
in the backseat again really takes you
back doesn't just you and me and Gabe
Mari you're right stop it Gabe
if I just close my eyes we're right back
where we were all of us together do what
I do try to think about the nice stuff
not everything that happened after huh
gotcha
oh come on that's not even a good rule
still gotcha you didn't stop you don't
got me Clemmy
you don't got claiming for [ __ ] you
haven't noticed Gabe's got a little
crush on nope nope nope nope Gabe [ __ ]
you game time
[ __ ] game you light like sir you get it
no long as it doesn't go anywhere
yeah no you're saying you don't think
they're adorable together no complicated
game climbs got history
we've all got history javi yeah gaben
got his super shades
it's so normal you know like as crazy as
things get that's terrible and tragic
and just plain stupid there's nothing
more wonderfully ordinary has two kids
falling for each other no no one get
there one kid but to feel something that
intensely for another person is it bad
if I kind of envy them those early days
before you get up the courage to say
exactly what's on yeah you're right
there's only one option and we're gonna
have to castrate gate no no you don't
it's unfair
that's all I'm saying that they're
feeling what they're feeling right now
and when that Sun gets a little higher
it's right back to the fight
Gabe's dead I just wish he could have
had a childhood you know I wish I could
have given them that hamon Wyman's too
mature for Gabe you're right guys they
deserved better than this that's why
we're doing this thing right and that
makes us well he can have a better life
after everything said and done you're
right I know you're right I hope you
know javi having you there with me right
by my side all this time that's what
made the difference
you're so sure of what you're doing all
this for you didn't run away
you could have three-fitty yeah thank
you no away honestly I'm not that sure
of anything right now gang just trying
to do my thing here don't say that
I get it there is no graceful way to say
this so I'm just gonna say it I know
we've had moments you and I and there
please a little hot yes and a little
confusing yes maybe some of them haven't
meant anything at all
but before whatever happened tomorrow
yes already I need you to know whatever
this thing is between us I want to give
it a chance and I know the fact that
David is back in our lives so [ __ ]
cool always thing a little more
complicated but I didn't realize I'd
really like to know before things get
crazy yeah I want to be with you what do
you want go for it we got a try right
just jumped in what'd I miss
gave us an [ __ ] Clementine is too
good for him and he's about to get
castrated yes yes okay yeah [ __ ] we're
doing this if you realize we're gonna
have to have a weird conversation with
David right it's the right way to play
this he already got the sense I was
away it's okay I told her wait
what we don't have to have the
conversation what exactly did you tell
him that you were done with him that it
was over we really say that and we're
secret to tell javi
don't bring the truck if they see it
they'll kill him right away
ah just get into the squirrel [ __ ] we
got to get over there oh boy a blessing
thanks Sam W
see Leslie parish agent with the truck
keep the walkie close by we'll tell you
as soon as we've got David all right
this is the last part of this episode I
hope someone's gonna die someone's gonna
die please nothing else from Ava nope
and it sounds like a crowd out there
it sounded like Ava got cut off by
something or somebody wish we had some
idea of what we're heading into like is
the whole plan shot or did she just have
a little setback you can't get
distracted I don't know what happened on
the other side but it doesn't change
what we have to do I just wish we had a
little more information that's all we're
not gonna know what went wrong until we
actually do this thing so game shutout
already no you're not gonna do anyone or
anything Gabe we just have to remember
we're going to do something risky we've
got to make sure we protect it ourselves
exactly we're gonna get dad back we
can't fight fair
Felix you are stupid on a good way thank
you appreciate it
that's the nicest thing someone's ever
said to me here it goes what do you guys
think if there was a choice to save him
or not should we take it I don't know we
can't wait for the others can we for
years now Richmond has been governed by
what Jamie Chill the Prince initiate
strong council strong community but
unfortunately the actions of one of the
members of that council our security
expert David Garcia have put us always
lying to all of you yes I'm sorry to
have to show you this truly I am but you
all need to save him just look what he's
done
Oh him murder Lonnie with my own eyes
can't can't save him you cut down in
their prime is this who we want in
charge someone this reckless this cruel
not if I have anything to do with it I
can't believe this is really happening
she should probably not be here Gabe
honestly he can't do this to him he's
kept him see try to keep you cool
Jones smart but we're smarter thank you
saying to be careful we can't screw this
up Bobby I heard you were planning to
crash our little party why did you come
out up here
show your face to everyone yeah do it
I'm sure these people would like to hear
what you have to say [ __ ] that and [ __ ]
you John I don't have anything to say to
someone who [ __ ] talks my family don't
make this harder on yourself of iere get
up here now she knows we're here now he
might as well okay come on we can do
this my [ __ ] guy he look sister fair
we both know you killed dr. lingard why
javi why would you do that to us
yes the only surgeon in a hundred mile
radius but you didn't care about that
you God he deserved to die dr. lingard
had a problem he couldn't stay out of
his own supply he asked me to put him
out of his misery I was only doing what
he wanted sorry if I don't take your
word for it
too bad you killed the only man who
could back up your story
no Clementine was their prime and time
was theirs in conversation with your
friend Eleanor last night isn't that
right Eleanor
that's that's right wait Eleanore ready
meow coming here today to take me out
Eleanor don't know how you thought you
were going to pull it off considering
it's all of us against the three of you
and that's exactly what I'm planning to
do appreciate the honesty
which makes this so much harder here in
Richmond people who put themselves
before the group don't last long bring
them out
Oh ah [ __ ] a mistake ah we're [ __ ]
guys it's time kill the ACE he told his
people where to find our guns supply and
sure enough they picked us clean you
really thought you could ride into town
and staged a coup with our own damn
weapons something like that I can't just
let it go
you've put me in a no-win situation here
so I recognize anything to you but of
them deserve to die for their crimes
however Tommy I'll let you spare one of
them just one no no Joe don't not after
what they tried to do you may be guilty
of bringing them into this but they
chose to go along with it is this the
kind of leadership you've got in store
for Richmond torturing people with your
stupid power games just this isn't a
game hobby it's about time you learn
that Joan are you sure about this take
Gabe instead kill all these people
it's really up to Harvey isn't it all
eyes are on you maybe this will help you
make up your mind boys
bourgeois Thanks yes she should Gary
Busey gonna be Gabe your friend oh [ __ ]
okay guys seriously for real tell me in
the comments I'll make a straw poll I'll
make a [ __ ] straw poll okay I'm
really curious cuz I honestly don't know
okay
I'll link it in the chat tell me I don't
know if I had to pick I would go with
save trip because I don't like Ava that
much let's see what the straw poll is
say 54 it's literally 5050 Morris
towards trip [ __ ] it's more towards trip
so [ __ ] stupid you can't be serious
god damn you Jew trip it's winning
trip is winning it's very close if the
court were saying how 55% 49 oh [ __ ] ah
okay it's red
he's invaluable huge pop sorry Ava gets
wrong with you can pay me happy but
sticking up for your own people shooting
wait I said trip should live
you did but there's something else you
need to understand I'm a [ __ ] snitch
no no figures I can do anything I want
what are you back [ __ ] [ __ ] do it do
it
no I really shot him ah damn it
now David damn oh man a lot of people of
people are going left and right here
mate hey the [ __ ] guard again he
looks so down I can't believe this
these are how we do things this is
madness stop or clicked
is this the process you trusting no
think about this hobby you know what's
gonna happen you you ready for that tell
her we don't murder enrichment we exile
that's how we've always done things how
about you take David and the rest of
your people and just get the hell out go
far away from Richmond and then whatever
you do is up to you
I'm sure the hurt outside was like that
she think she's sending us out there to
die she's counting on everybody put your
guns away we're gonna handle this
peacefully yeah but what about trip then
huh just shoot game what trip don't
listen to them javi they're [ __ ]
butchers Oliver
shoot that [ __ ] take her out she
deserves it
if you don't do it I [ __ ] will
oh my god what do we do now she were
doing that a straw poll that was really
fun to see you guys vote okay I'll do a
nice truffle okay okay okay okay okay
all right shoot or take the deal create
a poll I'm creating a poll all right
looking in the chat I'm looking in chat
Viking hipster is dead I'm so [ __ ]
pissed god damn god damn my results okay
what do we got everyone is saying shoot
Joan everyone we got 86 percent saying
shooting Joan how long how long do I get
to pick I'm worried I take the deal is
catching up man all right I think I I
think I should just shoot the [ __ ] show
No
save him holy [ __ ] he shooter finally
somehow ha ha ha ha lucky can you be oh
my god hell yeah
save him oh god he's gonna kill gate let
him ha that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] bullet why do you shoot
me a nut Gabe not come on that was my
chance
ok alright
Adam you're welcome Gabe you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right let's pull them away got to
him meat shields everywhere
[Music]
son of a [ __ ] get back here
we can hurry to cover me we gotta make
things right
okay come on Gabe
kale game Gabe Mustang
[Music]
you're helping game eat you go on go
Gabe get the [ __ ] out thanks no we
missed [ __ ] shoot ha
I was just gonna aim somebody people
dyin man mr. rifle go Clemmy yeah I want
to kill him I'm so tired of him gotta
help limp I know it was my favorite
guard did you have to go and shoot her
just everyone voted for it press Q to
throw keys fires oh we're dead now
oh [ __ ] it said your farts the most
lethal gas oh boy
[Music]
cell-cell take this labor hi how you
doing buddy oh she came anyway she's
coming for us
[Music]
Oh mall on top Oh Oh No
have you heard of brakes oh oh oh oh why
wasn't it game
[Laughter]
the texture looks in impeccable look at
that [ __ ] that's some necks now that's
some next-gen zombie key textures me hey
it feels real it feels like it's right
there
No
Dana Nana nanana nanan some Riverdale
AFTRA no just me
[ __ ] man that so much happened there in
the end wow that was fun it was a bit
slow but I really enjoy doing the stream
like this okay let's let's see here
what do you guys think did you promised
help care with the family 90s okay well
that was obvious alright did you respond
to doctor lingers requests that was
pretty 50/50 1.4 players let Clement I
decide lingers face oh you could do that
that's kind of cool did you tell Kate
that you have feelings for her
yeah everyone did ah what you guys voted
differently interesting I would have go
with him anyway and wow that's
interesting
so many of you guys want her dead but
here it was like 50/50 that's
interesting that's really interesting
okay so we have one more episode left of
no thanks of the telltale Walking Dead
[Music]
that's cool I'll do monster all Pauls
that was fun that was really fun
thanks to everyone all the sponsors if
you go to gaming youtube.com slash
PewDiePie there's a sponsor button there
and if you want sponsor that would
really help out a lot we really
appreciate it if you enjoy this
livestream thank you so much it's a bit
late so I actually got to go
can't keep can keep the lady waiting for
too long you know I'm saying how does
this look how does it this is look good
it's more I'm about you guys enjoy this
I might do more live streams or
playthroughs but I'll keep making my
videos like I normally do you know you
know I'm saying you know I'm saying I'll
do something super chat and then I'll be
[ __ ] their [ __ ] out of here me
denon and then and I love the Riverdale
outer it's so [ __ ] good I can't tell
what's the right aspect ratio all right
we got Chris are give me back my money
give it back right now
all right Chris are its back I I PayPal
you are refunded it thank you awesome
gamer for became your sponsor let's
let's unlock the hell hell hole and and
and Stella hey Pitts
watch you since you I was a teenager I
really enjoy a new content feel like
you're trying to grew up with me oh
that's nice thank you Dave phrase can
everyone still here sub to me help me
what the [ __ ] great great road to 1k
subs day phrase help how about a hip all
day how do I set the chat here I'm gonna
see here okay everyone can chat now
there's gonna be [ __ ] crazy
doesn't seem like it made a difference
no-one's commenting anyway what the [ __ ]
why isn't one commenting it should be
open for everyone
hanker es treats tava hey can you please
try and pronounce my name again well I
tried peg qu es trataba that it but I do
it right heip it's my birthday on May 9
can I get a can I get him a name a job
yeah there you go
your wish is my command it should be
able for everyone to comment but it
doesn't seem like that's happening
that's weird
maybe there's a glitch thanks to
everyone for watching I understand if
you gotta go this is fun
Aleksander Juvonen ik can have a
breakfast yes you can yes you can pure
max one brofist Felix brought us to you
main Paul Ramirez I really like the
socks you're wearing right now thank you
sexy when I get to VidCon I plan on
meeting I'll probably want to go into
VidCon this year
sorry but if I go papa me check welcome
doc slurp new sponsor
appreciate you Rayette Tiwari could you
really appreciate you follow me in a
[ __ ] Lord and six six six
I'll follow for a bit but I won't like
say father because I'll get family with
a bunch of people oh now with the chat
is off there you go holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's going fast
hopefully [ __ ] [ __ ] speed of light
it's your boy Peter pie I had one sub
but then my mom unsub can you check out
my channel that was a joke by the way
love you food pipe please some more
strawberry panties I was sweet there was
a lot of nice comment on that video I
really appreciate that it's a bit weird
to make Ben Bob Jill burrito hey pigs
can try and pronounce my name love you
hideous Ben Bob Gilbert uh I think I got
it I got nailed it I'm ed all zoo baby
keep up the good work follow me on
instagram sorry
I gots no more Instagram requests
I'll suck your dick I'll slap your ass
but I will follow in and stuff look at
the chat welcome new sponsored law thank
you appreciate you we can [ __ ] chat
so home Rasmus Larsen
thanks for livestream appreciate you man
okay guys I realize it's 6:30 I should
really get home it's a really fun had a
really fun day I hope you guys enjoy the
live streams I would love to do more of
these you guys are [ __ ] awesome it's
really fun hanging out with you guys
honestly you're cool people I appreciate
you appreciate you being here breakfast
everyone everyone tapping breakfast in
the chat thank you Samsung dimension say
in your best want to be filthy frankly
Sam hey I forgot
Samsung spread you're [ __ ] pathetic
roughest guys can I get a breakfast all
right take care guys see you next time
stay awesome bris